Alice:起床
Alice: Wake up
Alice:起床起床
Alice: Wake up, wake up
Alice:收拾
Alice: Clean up
Alice:很结实好
Alice: Very sturdy, good
Alice:把你的地雷拿走
Alice: Take your landmine away
Alice:不刷这啥
Alice: No brushing, what is this?
其他人：这还有一个
Other people: There's another one here
Alice:搁底下吧
Alice: Put it underneath
其他人：手机充电宝
Other people: Phone charger
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm-hmm
Alice:把这个折一下
Alice: Fold this
Alice:好
Alice: Okay
其他人：ok
Other people: Okay
Alice:床皱皱巴巴的
Alice: The bed is all wrinkled
其他人：哎上面那个窗帘要掉按一按
Other people: Hey, the curtain up there is falling, press it
其他人：够得着吗
Other people: Can you reach it?
Alice:哈哈哈贴的真是
Alice: Haha, it's really stuck
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Alice:完美
Alice: Perfect
Alice:你看好完美啊
Alice: Look, it's perfect, right?
Alice:把垃圾桶收起来吧
Alice: Put the trash can away
Alice:往那边一推
Alice: Push it over there
Alice:我拖鞋呢
Alice: Where are my slippers?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Alice:你不穿你的鞋吗
Alice: Aren't you wearing your shoes?
其他人：那是谁啊
Other people: Whose are those?
Alice:狗的
Alice: The dog's
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice:不是我肯定不会脱
Alice: It's not me, I definitely wouldn't take them off
Alice:那肯定是你脱那的
Alice: It must have been you who took them off there
其他人：那我脱那我鞋还在这
其他人：我怎么上来了
Alice:呵呵我哪知道啊
Alice:给我呵呵呵
Alice:你是狗
Alice:神经病吧你
其他人：你把我鞋踹走了
其他人：你还跟个鞋
Alice:哈哈你放屁
Alice:肯定不是我搁那的
Alice:行去去去
Alice:先扫我们的吧
Alice:我们的容易掉
Jake:好
Alice:哪有耳机啊
Alice:桌上呢
Alice:真是个贴心的小姐姐呢
Alice:小姐姐你怎么感觉这床怪怪的嘞
Alice:就这吧谁家床这么干净
Alice:反正我的不太像
Alice:走吧小姐姐
Alice: Let's go, girl.
Alice:哎呀就这吧
Alice: Oh well, this will do.
Alice:小姐姐
Alice: Hey girl.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
其他人：去哪啊楼上楼下啊
Others: Where to? Upstairs or downstairs?
Alice:楼下呗
Alice: Downstairs.
Alice:小姐姐你
Alice: Hey girl, you...
Alice:我渴了刘婷
Alice: I'm thirsty, Liu Ting.
其他人：渴着吧
Others: Stay thirsty then.
Alice:不喝桃子
Alice: No peach drink.
Alice:我想喝水
Alice: I want water.
Jake:刚拿了一个杯子
Jake: Just got a cup.
Jake:哈哈哈你们就说渴了
Jake: Haha, you guys just say you're thirsty.
Alice:有
Alice: Yes.
Alice:你以为跟你一样
Alice: You think like you...
Alice:一晚上猛涨
Alice: Grow all night.
Alice:我想喝水
Alice: I want water.
其他人：自己拿去
Others: Get it yourself.
Alice:没长手
Alice: I don't have hands.
其他人：那就别喝了
Others: Then don't drink.
Alice:好吧那我不喝了
Alice: Okay then I won't drink anymore.
Alice:你家是不是比这还舒服呢
Alice: Is your home more comfortable than this?
Alice:又宽敞
Alice: It's more spacious.
Alice:又大
Alice: And bigger.
其他人：院确实有点小
Others: The yard is indeed a bit small.
其他人：这房子不都是
Others: Aren't these houses
其他人：改了用来做民宿吗太密了
Others: renovated to be homestays? It's too crowded.
Alice:是啊
Alice: Yeah.
Jake:喝点
Jake: Have a drink.
其他人：你你好大的架子
Others: Wow, you've got some nerve.
其他人：还让逼个boss给你拿杯子
Others: Making the boss get you a cup.
其他人：我天你
Others: Oh my, you...
Jake:请请你你也来你也来
Jake: Please, you too, you too.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:我不喝这啥呀水
Jake:那可不
Jake: Of course.
Alice:嗯不用给我倒了
Alice: No need to pour for me.
Alice:谢谢你嗯
Alice: Thank you.
Jake:你不要了
Jake: You don't want it?
Jake:那给您倒
Jake: Then I'll pour for you.
其他人：哎呦
Others: Oh wow.
其他人：太客气了
Others: So polite.
Jake:来你要多少
Jake: How much do you want?
其他人：够了谢谢
Others: That's enough, thank you.
Jake:这么多我去
Jake: This much? Wow.
Jake:瞧不起我们
Jake: Looking down on us?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Alice:你倒这么多
Alice: You poured so much.
Alice:你还不如拿个一次性纸杯呢
Alice: You might as well use a disposable cup.
Alice:哎呦喝桃汁能给你喝微醺了
Alice: Oh my, drinking peach juice can get you tipsy.
Jake:来干杯
Jake: Come on, cheers.
Jake:哎你你你也干哎哈哈
Jake: Hey, you, you, you too, haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
其他人：咱们的窗帘能撑住吗
Others: Can our curtains hold up?
Alice:反正掉了都怪你
Alice: Anyway, if they fall, it's your fault.
Jake:哦要扫了是吧
Jake: Oh, they need to be swept?
Alice:对啊哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Yeah, hahaha.
Jake:对啊草
Jake: Oh yeah, forgot, haha.
Jake:给忘了哈哈哈哈
Jake: Totally forgot, hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake:给忘了忘了要扫
Jake: Oh, I forgot, forgot to sweep.
Alice:我还以为他另有安排
Alice: I thought he had other plans.
Lucia: 啊什么
Lucia: What?
Alice:他不应该在楼上扫完了吗
Alice: Shouldn't he have finished sweeping upstairs?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:然后他要扫楼下了
Alice: Then he was supposed to sweep downstairs.
Alice:然后但是他坐这跟我们喝桃汁
Alice: But instead, he's sitting here drinking peach juice with us.
Alice:我想着他是不是另有安排
Alice: I wondered if he had other plans.
Alice:然后呢哈哈
Alice: Then, haha.
Alice:一问他忘了
Alice: Turns out he just forgot.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我们的leader是一个
Lucia: Our leader is really...
Lucia: 非常随和的人
Lucia: ...a very easy-going person.
其他人：性情中人
Others: A person of character.
Lucia: 性情中人
Lucia: A person of character.
Lucia: 对对对性情中人
Lucia: Yes, yes, a person of character.
其他人： 工作走到哪做到哪对对
Others: Works wherever he goes, right.
Jake:它这个桃汁他误事你知道吗
Jake: This peach juice is causing trouble, you know?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你这还没喝酒呢就开始误事了
Lucia: You haven't even had any alcohol yet and it's already causing trouble.
Jake:桃汁
Jake: Peach juice.
Lucia: 啊他拿了4个杯子
Lucia: Oh, he brought four cups.
Lucia: 那我也喝一个吧
Lucia: I'll have one too then.
Lucia: 谢谢老板
Lucia: Thanks, boss.
其他人：这俩是没用过的
Others: These two haven't been used.
Lucia: 可心喝吗
Lucia: Katrina, want some?
Alice:不喝了
Alice: No, I'm good.
Lucia: 那我给老板倒点
Lucia: Then I'll pour some for the boss.
Lucia: 哎老板已经喝过了
Lucia: Oh, the boss already drank some.
其他人：刚喝完就误事
Others: He already caused trouble right after drinking.
Lucia: 刚喝完就误事了
Lucia: He caused trouble right after drinking.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 给他倒点
Lucia: Pour him some.
Lucia: 等他回来喝
Lucia: For when he comes back.
Lucia: 再无下一场不
Lucia: Is there another round?
Lucia: 是
Lucia: Yes.
其他人：（歌词）宇宙的扭曲
Others: (Lyrics) The distortion of the universe.
其他人：（歌词）我猜不在意我猜
Others: (Lyrics) I guess I don't care, I guess.
Lucia: 哎这首歌好熟悉啊
Lucia: Oh, this song sounds so familiar.
Lucia: 感觉听过
Lucia: Feels like I've heard it before.
其他人： 告5人还是说什么告5人呢
Others: Are you suing 5 people or what about 5 people?
Alice:这么没有标志的声音
Alice: Such an unremarkable voice.
Lucia: 姐妹可以加你的微信吗
Lucia: Hey girl, can I add you on WeChat?
Alice:他配吗
Alice: Is he even worthy?
其他人：我就要
Others: I want to.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人：我今天加
Others: I'll add you today.
其他人：加也得加
Others: You have to add.
其他人：不加也得加
Others: Even if you don't want to, you have to add.
Lucia: 收到了我要加你的微信
Lucia: Got it, I want to add you on WeChat.
Alice:我想加你的微信
Alice: I want to add you on WeChat.
Alice:小姐姐
Alice: Girl
其他人：先把你删掉再加好吗
Others: Let's delete you first and then add, okay?
Lucia: 你俩不熟吗哈哈哈
Lucia: Aren't you two familiar? Hahaha
Alice:烦烦死你了
Alice: So annoying, you're driving me nuts.
其他人：真是的
Others: Seriously
Lucia: 原来你俩不熟啊
Lucia: So you two aren't familiar?
Alice:对不认识
Alice: Yeah, don't know him.
Lucia: 是是我唐突了
Lucia: Oh, I was being abrupt.
Alice:不太认识他
Alice: I'm not very familiar with him.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
其他人：不是你怎么叫啊
Others: If not, why did you call?
Lucia: 不是你怎么叫
Lucia: Why did you call then?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Lucia: 啊在说我
Lucia: Oh, talking about me.
Lucia: 这名字有点抽象
Lucia: This name is kind of abstract.
Lucia: 确实大家都这么说
Lucia: Indeed, everyone says that.
其他人：天呐备注你就叫助理啊
Others: Oh my, your note just says "assistant"?
Lucia: 不是不是
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 我会给你发名字的
Lucia: I'll send you the name.
其他人：OK OK
Alice:他叫Lucy啊
Alice: He's called Lucia.
Lucia: 对对你叫露西亚也行
Lucia: Yes, yes, you can call me Lucia too.
其他人：罗马
Others: Roma
Lucia: 也可以没事我
Lucia: It's fine, really.
Alice:罗马姐是吗
Alice: Roma, right?
其他人：罗马分部
Others: Roma division.
Lucia: 罗马姐
Lucia: Roma
Lucia: 我妈姐姐是可以的
Lucia: My mom, sister, it's fine.
Lucia: 同学你叫什么名字
Lucia: Classmate, what's your name?
Lucia: 我叫姜璐呀
Lucia: My name is Jiang Lu.
Alice:刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting.
其他人：他念了一天了
Others: He's been saying it all day.
其他人：他在那我天天晚上听不见
Others: I can't hear him every night.
其他人：长剪子了都
Others: He's cutting long scissors.
Lucia: 但是礼节性的还是问一下
Lucia: But it's still polite to ask.
Alice:刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈对我不但我
Lucia: Haha, right, I not only...
Alice:昌平姐
Alice: Sister Changping.
Lucia: 虽然我叫朱立文建材罗马分部
Lucia: Although my name is Zhu Liwen Building Materials, Rome Branch.
Lucia: 但我不叫朱立文哈哈
Lucia: But my name is not Zhu Liwen, haha.
Alice:这是昌平姐
Alice: This is Sister Changping.
Alice:昌平别墅姐
Alice: Sister Changping from the villa.
其他人：你名字太有迷惑性了
Others: Your name is so confusing.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Lucia: 要的就是这个效果
Lucia: That's exactly the effect I wanted.
Alice:昌平别墅姐
Alice: Sister Changping from the villa.
Lucia: 没有让我来
Lucia: No, let me...
Alice:什么时候能去你家床上睡
Alice: When can I sleep in your bed?
其他人：想得美哈哈
Others: Dream on, haha.
Lucia: 让我来认真的解释一下
Lucia: Let me explain seriously.
Lucia: 没有就是是为了
Lucia: No, it's because...
Lucia: 就是在国内点外卖的时候
Lucia: When I order takeout in China,
Lucia: 看起来像男生
Lucia: it looks like a guy's name.
Lucia: 就是大概是那种AA建材猪哥的这种
Lucia: It's like those AA building materials, Zhugo kind of names.
其他人：哦大概懂了大概懂了
Others: Oh, I kind of get it.
Lucia: 这种对我淘宝也会换一个
Lucia: So on Taobao, I would also change it.
其他人：我淘宝也会换一个名字
Others: I would change my name on Taobao too.
其他人：就比如说
Others: For example,
Alice:AA海鲜批发
Alice: AA Seafood Wholesale.
Alice:刘姐哈哈哈
Alice: Sister Liu, haha.
Lucia: 但是就是因为我很喜欢罗马这个城市
Lucia: But it's because I really like the city of Rome.
Alice:烦我烦我
Alice: Annoying, annoying.
Alice:啥烦我啊
Alice: What's annoying?
Lucia: 然后所以我就灵机一动
Lucia: So I had a sudden idea.
Lucia: 把它写成了朱立文建材罗马分部
Lucia: And wrote it as Zhu Liwen Building Materials, Rome Branch.
Lucia: 就你也可以叫我建材朱哥哈哈
Lucia: You can also call me Building Materials Zhugo, haha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：咿呀谁认得出来呀我天
Other people: Oh my, who can recognize that?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Alice:啊哎呀哈哈哈你可
Alice: Ah, haha, you...
Lucia: 你你可以
Lucia: You, you can...
Lucia: 你可以给我备注AA建材朱哥
Lucia: You can save my contact as AA Building Materials Zhu Ge.
Lucia: 这样你要找我
Lucia: So when you need me...
Lucia: 就是购买一些建材或者施工的时候
Lucia: For buying building materials or during construction...
Lucia: 就比较方便找到我
Lucia: It will be easier to find me.
Alice:刘婷刘婷
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 没事我开玩笑的
Lucia: It's okay, I'm just kidding.
Lucia: 你随便备注
Lucia: Save it however you like.
Jake:我我第一次家里的时候
Jake: When I was at home for the first time...
Jake:我以为你反向推销
Jake: I thought you were reverse selling.
Jake:你知道反向推销
Jake: Do you know about reverse selling?
Lucia: 我吗哈
Lucia: Me? Haha
Jake:投了个随便投了个简历
Jake: Just randomly submitted a resume.
Jake:然后让我去连续里买建材
Jake: And then made me go buy building materials.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:毕竟我们也要租耗子啊
Jake: After all, we also need to rent a mouse.
Lucia: 哦其实也可以
Lucia: Oh, actually that works too.
Lucia: 要不下次您考虑我一下
Lucia: How about considering me next time?
Jake:哎好嘞
Jake: Sure thing.
Alice:刘婷刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting, Liu Ting.
Lucia: 给我一个机会
Lucia: Give me a chance.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:你卖什么呀
Jake: What do you sell?
Lucia: 建材啊不是写的很清楚吗
Lucia: Building materials, isn't it clearly written?
Jake:建材多了
Jake: There are many kinds of building materials.
Jake:对哪哪种啊
Jake: Which type specifically?
Lucia: 呃只只有只有你想不到
Lucia: Uh, anything you can think of.
Lucia: 没有我卖不了
Lucia: I can sell it all.
Jake:好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 这个这个
Lucia: This, this...
Lucia: 这个供货渠道啊
Lucia: This supply channel...
Lucia: 这个厂房啊都是非常的完备的
Lucia: This factory is very well-equipped.
Jake:好
Jake: Good.
Lucia: 然后跟这些供货商
Lucia: And we have...
Lucia: 有很多年良好的合作关系
Lucia: Many years of good cooperation with these suppliers.
Lucia: 就是这质量啊
Lucia: It's about the quality.
Lucia: 您大可放心啊
Lucia: You can rest assured.
Jake:好好好下回买
Jake: Okay, okay, we'll buy it next time.
Lucia: 胡说八道
Lucia: Nonsense.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Jake:下次用EGB买你的建材
Jake: Next time, I'll use EGB to buy your building materials.
Lucia: 对对对我今天早上还
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, I was just telling my boss this morning.
Lucia: 我今天早上还和领导说
Lucia: I was telling my boss this morning.
Lucia: 等到他成为了埃隆马斯克的时候
Lucia: When he becomes Elon Musk.
Lucia: 就是一定要记得
Lucia: He has to remember.
Jake:哼哼
Jake: Hmm hmm.
Lucia: 就是给我们这个EOB带带货
Lucia: To help promote our EOB.
Lucia: 哈哈哈笑死
Lucia: Haha, it's so funny.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
其他人：怎么变异了
Others: Why did it mutate?
其他人：你这个水
Others: Your water...
Alice:好听啊
Alice: Sounds good.
Alice:西游记
Alice: Journey to the West.
Lucia: 那个丢丢丢吗
Lucia: Is that the throw throw throw thing?
Lucia: 他怎么还没有开始丢丢丢
Lucia: Why hasn't he started throwing yet?
其他人：啊来了哈哈哈
Others: Ah, here it comes, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
其他人：你有没有潮一点的英文名啊
Others: Do you have a cooler English name?
Alice:你意思我的英文名不够潮
Alice: You mean my English name isn't cool enough?
其他人： 呃比如
Others: Uh, like...
Lucia: Alice
Lucia: Alice.
Alice:昨天晚上你没看那个片吗
Alice: Didn't you watch that movie last night?
其他人：没有
Others: No.
Lucia: 没有你们昨天晚上看啥了
Lucia: No, what did you watch last night?
Alice:你放屁
Alice: You're talking nonsense.
其他人：上面有你的名吗就是
Others: Was your name in it?
Lucia: 有你的名吗
Lucia: Was your name in it?
Lucia: 就是爱丽丝梦游仙境吗
Lucia: Like Alice in Wonderland?
其他人：不是就是你拍的那个
Others: No, the one you shot.
其他人：那个AI制作的那个
Others: The one made by AI.
Alice:啊接机的人忘给我拍了
Alice: Ah, the person picking me up forgot to film it.
Alice:但是也出现我的名了呀
Alice: But my name did appear!
Alice:你就不细心
Alice: You just weren't paying attention.
Alice:你耳朵长的干嘛使的
Alice: What are your ears for?
Lucia: 我当他放那个片是我当时还没上来
Lucia: When he played that movie, I hadn't come up yet.
Lucia: 但是就是就是
Lucia: But it's just, just...
Lucia: 他自我介绍的时候说他叫Alice
Lucia: When he introduced himself, he said his name was Alice.
Lucia: 是这个名吗
Lucia: Is that the name?
Lucia: 还是你跟我一样经常换名啊其实a a
Lucia: Or do you change names often like me, actually, a a
Alice:没有我就喜欢爱丽丝这个名字哈哈哈
Alice: No, I just like the name Alice, hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:哎哎哎爱丽丝
Alice: Hey hey hey, Alice.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Lucia: 你这名本来就是a开头的
Lucia: Your name already starts with an "A."
Lucia: 还要再加a
Lucia: And you still add another "A."
Alice:对AA哎哎
Alice: Yeah, AA, hey hey.
其他人：4A级哈哈哈
Others: 4A, hahaha.
Lucia: 四四a g
Lucia: Four, four A, G.
其他人：4A级爱丽丝
Others: 4A Alice.
Lucia: Alice欢迎进入我的心
Lucia: Alice, welcome to my heart.
Alice:欢迎进入我的心哈哈哈
Alice: Welcome to my heart, hahaha.
Lucia: 我推销点啥呢
Lucia: What should I sell?
Lucia: 我想想
Lucia: Let me think.
Lucia: 我把我名字改成我推销的东西
Lucia: I'll change my name to what I'm selling.
Alice:那刘婷你得卖啥呀
Alice: So, Liu Chen, what should you sell?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Alice:哈哈哈你得卖你的低质
Alice: Hahaha, you should sell your low-quality
Alice:小视频哈哈
Alice: short videos, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
其他人：抖家推广
Others: Douyin promotion.
Alice:真服了天天拍下来弱智小视频
Alice: Seriously, filming those dumb short videos every day.
Alice:还老拉我一起拍
Alice: And always dragging me to film them.
Alice:对啊我    哈哈哈
Alice: Yeah, I, hahaha.
Lucia: 全渠道推广刘总
Lucia: All-channel promotion, Mr. Liu.
Alice:给你个心刘婷姐
Alice: Here's a heart for you, Liu Ting.
Lucia: 特别专业
Lucia: Very professional.
Alice:装死了在这哈哈哈
Alice: Playing dead here, hahaha.
其他人：会有错觉吗
Others: Do you have the illusion?
其他人：这首歌好像没有歌词耶
Others: that this song seems to have no lyrics?
Alice:本来就没有啊
Alice: It really has no lyrics.
Lucia: 有不是有那个
Lucia: It has, doesn't it have that...
Lucia: 你挑着担
Lucia: "You bear the load."
Alice:那是另一首
Alice: That's a different song.
Lucia: 不是一首啊
Lucia: It's not the same song?
Alice:那是路敢问路在何方
Alice: That's the path, dare to ask where the path is.
Alice:这是云宫训音
Alice: This is the Cloud Palace's sound training.
Lucia: 两个都丢丢丢吗
Lucia: Are both of them missing?
Alice:那个没有
Alice: That one's not.
Alice:搞什么啦
Alice: What are you doing?
其他人：这个AA Alice刚才不是在午休吗
Others: This AA, wasn't Alice just taking a nap?
其他人：然后他是特意把我的拖鞋藏起来了
Others: And then he hid my slippers on purpose.
Alice:我我我藏你拖鞋干啥
Alice: Why would I hide your slippers?
Alice:你拖鞋老香
Alice: Your slippers smell nice.
Alice:是吗
Alice: Really?
其他人：他把我拖鞋藏起来然后我洗的澡
Others: He hid my slippers and I took a bath.
其他人：然后我先下去把拖鞋穿走
Others: Then I went downstairs with my slippers on.
其他人：他就说啊我的拖鞋在哪
Others: He said, "Where are my slippers?"
Alice:哈哈你放屁
Alice: Haha, you're talking nonsense.
Alice:你胡扯
Alice: You're making stuff up.
其他人：明明是你做贼心虚
Others: Clearly, you're feeling guilty.
Alice:谁擦拖鞋谁是狗行吧
Alice: Whoever wipes the slippers is a dog, alright?
Alice:不是我藏的我藏拖鞋干啥
Alice: It wasn't me who hid them. Why would I hide your slippers?
其他人：谁看见后头都是狗
Others: Whoever sees it last is a dog.
Alice:说是开灯不是床头灯
Alice: You said to turn on the light, not the bedside lamp.
Alice:那是不小心一个回旋镖扎身上了吗
Alice: Was it an accident that a boomerang hit you?
Alice:周六日有空没
Alice: Are you free on the weekend?
Alice:咱俩就赏花吧
Alice: Let's go see the flowers.
其他人：没空
Others: No, I'm not free.
Alice:不是你凭啥没空呀
Alice: Why aren't you free?
其他人：我睡觉
Others: I'm sleeping.
Lucia: 你不是说来找我玩呢吗
Lucia: Didn't you say you were coming to play with me?
Alice:你不是都要走了吗
Alice: Aren't you leaving?
Alice:周六日这周
Alice: This weekend?
Lucia: 啊对那你不是说要去西安找我玩吗
Lucia: Ah, right. Didn't you say you were coming to Xi'an to visit me?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Huh?
Alice:去西安的旅程还没有定
Alice: The trip to Xi'an isn't confirmed yet.
Alice:五一我都还没想好回家还是不回家
Alice: I haven't decided if I'm going home for May Day.
Alice:我要回家的话我得回家一个多星期
Alice: If I go home, I'll be gone for more than a week.
Alice:不回家的话就不回了
Alice: If I don't go home, I just won't go.
Alice:看情况吧
Alice: Let's see how it goes.
Lucia: 你们宿舍是几个人
Lucia: How many people are in your dorm?
Alice:6个
Alice: Six.
其他人：你们宿舍不是上床下桌吗
Others: Isn't your dorm bunk beds with desks underneath?
Alice:你觉得我们宿舍有那么好的条件吗
Alice: Do you think our dorm is that fancy?
其他人：那你不天天在校吗
Other: Aren't you at school every day?
Alice:对啊啊你们研究生宿舍学啊
Alice: Yeah, you guys study in the graduate dorm, right?
Lucia: 你们研究生宿舍学啊
Lucia: You guys study in the graduate dorm, right?
Alice:对啊还没本
Alice: Yeah, it's not as good as undergrad.
Alice:还没本科学校好呢
Alice: It's not as good as the undergrad school.
其他人：嗯那你之前打视频
Other: Hmm, then the video call you made before...
Alice:我给你打的视频啊
Alice: The video call I made to you?
Alice:什么时候给你打视频了
Alice: When did I make a video call to you?
其他人：你显摆你那个茶叶的时候啊
Other: When you were showing off your tea!
Alice:什么茶叶啊
Alice: What tea?
Alice:等一下
Alice: Wait a second.
Alice:你等我想什么时候给你打个视频
Alice: Let me think, when did I make a video call to you?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:哎呦啊那是我在我桌子上啊
Alice: Oh, that was when I was at my desk.
其他人：你床上的桌子上
Other: The desk on your bed?
Alice:不是啊床是床
Alice: No, the bed is the bed.
Alice:桌子是桌子呀
Alice: The desk is the desk.
其他人：你又有床又有桌子
Other: So you have both a bed and a desk?
Alice:显示不放桌子只有床
Alice: It doesn't show a desk, only a bed.
其他人：等会你们大概什么构造
Other: Wait, what's the layout like?
Alice:是哎
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:其实我们那个床能我们那个屋子大小
Alice: Actually, our room is big enough.
Alice:能放6个上床下桌
Alice: We could fit six bunk beds with desks.
Alice:但是那个构造特别奇怪
Alice: But the layout is really weird.
Alice:然后所以就6张单独的桌
Alice: So we have six separate desks.
Alice:等于说那个空间就没有利用起来嘛
Alice: So the space isn't fully utilized.
Alice:然后住的也挤
Alice: It's cramped to live in.
Alice:学习也挤
Alice: And cramped to study in.
Alice:哎    是这样的
Alice: That's how it is at the Communication University of China.
Alice:年年换草皮
Alice: They change the turf every year.
Alice:年年换树
Alice: They change the trees every year.
Alice:就不知道给我们宿舍换一下
Alice: But they never change our dorm.
Alice:咦咦
Alice: Ugh.
Lucia: 他们是不是跟什么建材老板有合作
Lucia: Do they have a deal with some building material supplier?
Lucia: 然后所以就每年从他那哈哈哈
Lucia: So they buy turf and trees from them every year, haha.
Alice:哎谁知道呢
Alice: Who knows?
Lucia: 每年从他那买草皮和书
Lucia: They buy turf and trees from them every year.
Alice:那我们学校今年新装修的你知道吗
Alice: Did you know our school got a new renovation this year?
Alice:平地起一座桥知道吧
Alice: They built a bridge from scratch, you know?
Alice:跟什么风水大阵一样
Alice: It's like some kind of feng shui array.
Lucia: 给你们提供一些建筑
Lucia: I'll provide you guys with some construction materials.
Alice:真的风水风水阵一样
Alice: It really looks like a Feng Shui array.
Alice:就是好好的平路他给上面架个桥啊
Alice: It's like there's a perfectly good flat road, and they build a bridge over it.
Alice:又没水又没啥的
Alice: There's no water or anything.
Lucia: 我觉得我台词说多了
Lucia: I think I'm talking too much.
Lucia: 到时候AI就以为我真是做建材了
Lucia: The AI might actually think I work in construction.
Alice:没关系哈哈哈
Alice: It's okay, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈给AI输入一些错误数据
Lucia: Haha, let's feed the AI some wrong data.
其他人：嗯AI没有办法代替人类的方法
Others: Yeah, AI can't replace human methods.
Alice: 什么时候把我代替了呀
Alice: When will it replace me?
其他人：真他妈迫不及待的
Others: Can't wait for that to happen.
Alice:对啊我就不用干活了
Alice: Yeah, then I won't have to work.
Alice:换个歌
Alice: Change the song.
Lucia: 本来是希望AI来代替我干活了
Lucia: I initially hoped AI would replace my work.
Lucia: 结果现在AI代替我画画
Lucia: But now AI is replacing my drawing.
Alice:阿姨好
Alice: Hi, auntie.
Alice:阿姨现在还不能进去
Alice: Auntie, you can't go in yet.
Lucia: 您要稍微等会才能进去
Lucia: You'll have to wait a bit before you can go in.
Alice:嗯那个是
Alice: Um, that is...
Lucia: 就是里面
Lucia: It's inside.
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's fine.
Lucia: 外面可以
Lucia: Outside is okay.
Lucia: 外面您随便走
Lucia: You can walk around outside.
Lucia: 就是里面等会才
Lucia: But inside, you'll have to wait.
Alice:二楼也可以
Alice: The second floor is okay.
Alice:但是一楼不能进去
Alice: But you can't go to the first floor.
Alice:不要了
Alice: Forget it.
Lucia: 咱家能生产这么多垃圾
Lucia: Our house can produce so much trash.
Alice:一星期7天
Alice: Seven days a week.
Alice:然后这个地方已经收了好几次了
Alice: And this place has been cleaned up several times already.
Alice:咦
Alice: Huh?
Alice:刘婷刘婷刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting, Liu Ting, Liu Ting.
Alice:哎你什么时候回西安
Alice: Hey, when are you going back to Xi'an?
Lucia: 应该明天吧
Lucia: Probably tomorrow.
Lucia: 不过还没订票
Lucia: But I haven't booked my ticket yet.
Alice:可以这时候订票简单
Alice: You can book it easily now.
Alice:再过几天就不行了
Alice: In a few days, it won't be as easy.
Lucia: 对我先可以看看票
Lucia: Yeah, I'll check the tickets first.
Alice:哎这琵琶弹的真牛
Alice: Wow, this pipa playing is amazing.
Lucia: 明天嗯
Lucia: Tomorrow, um.
Lucia: 可心你寄不寄东西
Lucia: Kexin, are you sending anything?
Lucia: 明天快递
Lucia: Tomorrow's courier.
Alice:我没啥想寄的
Alice: I don't have anything I want to send.
Alice:我打算把我的桌布啥寄成给刘婷
Alice: I plan to send my tablecloth to Liu Ting.
Alice:然后把那个床单被罩跟地毯拿走
Alice: Then take away the bed sheet, quilt cover, and carpet.
Alice:其他的就不用
Alice: The rest doesn't matter.
Lucia: 我在想我那个小柜子怎么处理
Lucia: I'm wondering what to do with my little cabinet.
Alice:噔噔噔
Alice: Dun dun dun.
Lucia: 难道我要把它拎到高铁上拎回去吗
Lucia: Should I carry it back on the high-speed train?
Alice:太奇怪了
Alice: That's so weird.
Alice:那样很麻烦的
Alice: It's going to be a hassle.
Alice:你要是寄回去的话你得把它拆了吧
Alice: If you send it back, you have to disassemble it, right?
Lucia: 对我就算我哪怕拎着我也得把它拆了
Lucia: Yes, even if I carry it, I have to disassemble it.
Lucia: 感觉用一次实在是有点浪费
Lucia: Feels like a waste to use it just once.
其他人：对不要浪费
Others: Yes, don't waste it.
Alice:刘婷你会啥乐器吗
Alice: Liu Ting, do you play any instruments?
其他人：我会b box
Others: I can beatbox.
Alice:你会退堂鼓哈哈哈
Alice: You can play the quitting drum, haha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：箭在弦上也发不了呀
Others: The arrow is on the string but can't be shot.
Lucia: 哈哈箭在弦上也发
Lucia: Haha, the arrow on the string can be shot.
Alice:我回去得把我的那个课赶紧给上完了
Alice: I need to finish my class quickly when I get back.
Alice:不上完我怕他过期了
Alice: If I don't finish, it might expire.
Alice:我的古筝课还没上完
Alice: I haven't finished my guzheng class yet.
Alice:去年
Alice: Last year.
其他人：这么有才艺
Others: So talented.
Alice:被我装到了吧
Alice: Fooled you, right?
Alice:确实会没办法
Alice: I really can, no choice.
其他人：好吧
Alice:你要听我弹的吗
Alice: Do you want to hear me play?
Alice:我给你找找
Alice: I'll find it for you.
Alice:啊啊啊
Alice: Ah ah ah.
Alice:疼死老娘了
Alice: It hurts so much.
Lucia: 哎呀老娘眼镜没事吧
Lucia: Oh no, are my glasses okay?
Alice:我靠我都快被夹死了
Alice: Damn, I almost got pinched to death.
Alice:你问眼镜没事吧
Alice: Are your glasses okay?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:你没事吧
Alice: Are you alright?
Lucia: 哎他怎么还没扫完
Lucia: Hey, why isn't he done cleaning?
Lucia: 我想进去看看有啥吃的吧
Lucia: I want to go in and see if there's anything to eat.
Alice:这是伴奏啊
Alice: This is the accompaniment.
其他人：OK等等
Others: OK, hold on.
其他人：你开始弹的时候你提醒我们一声啊
Others: Let us know when you start playing.
Alice:但是这个进拍子有点错位了
Alice: But the beat is a bit off.
Alice:应该从这进
Alice: It should start from here.
Alice:然后我慢了一点
Alice: And I played a bit slower.
Jake:充会电没电了
Jake: Charge it, it's out of battery.
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Lucia: 巫巫室水准备好了
Lucia: The water in the Wuwu Room is ready.
Jake:哈哈哈好
Jake: Hahaha, okay.
Jake:这干啥呢品鉴
Jake: What are you doing? Tasting?
Alice:他不信我会弹古筝
Alice: He doesn't believe I can play the guzheng.
Alice:我给他放一下我弹的你的作品哦
Alice: I'll play a piece of your work for him.
其他人：自己的作品哦
Others: Your own piece.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:什么曲子呀
Jake: What piece is it?
Alice:一个流行曲打谱的
Alice: It's a popular song transcribed for guzheng.
Jake:扫扫了一半电没了充会
Jake: I was sweeping, and it ran out of battery. Charging it now.
Shure: 这是在这干嘛呢怎
Shure: What's going on here?
Shure: 么突然修身养性呢
Shure: Why the sudden self-cultivation?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈就是这几天过太苦了哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, it's been tough these days, hahaha.
Shure: 这是什么
Shure: What's this?
Shure: 这是生怒哀乐吗
Shure: Is this about birth, anger, sadness, and joy?
Alice:不是这是
Alice: No, this is...
其他人：自己弹的
Others: Playing our own.
其他人：推广一下
Others: Promoting it.
其他人：好古筝大使
Others: Great guzheng ambassador.
Shure: 这谁的古筝
Shure: Whose guzheng is this?
Alice:我的
Alice: Mine.
其他人：深藏不露
Others: Hidden talent.
其他人：嗯好挺
Others: Hmm, nice.
其他人：赏赏赏一杯好
Others: Appreciate, appreciate, a cup of good tea.
Jake:哈哈哈赏一片
Jake: Hahaha, appreciate a piece.
Alice:滚
Alice: Get lost.
Jake:赏易烊千玺一位
Jake: Appreciate Yi Yangqianxi.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:是吗
Jake: Really?
Alice:为啥要赏易烊千玺
Alice: Why appreciate Yi Yangqianxi?
Alice:啊哦
Alice: Uh-oh.
Jake:在这了吗
Jake: Is it here?
Lucia: 比较好赏顺手
Lucia: It's easier to handle this way.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:还好及时停的1%
Jake: Good thing we stopped it at 1% in time.
Jake:不然白扫了
Jake: Otherwise, it would have been scanned for nothing.
Alice:不好听
Alice: Doesn't sound good.
Alice:听歌吧
Alice: Let's listen to some music.
Alice:嗯嗯
Alice: Mm-hmm.
Jake:对你俩屋子我扫过了
Jake: Yeah, I already cleaned your room.
Alice:我俩的
Alice: Our room?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:你俩屋子我扫过了
Jake: I cleaned your room.
Alice:那是不是可以进去了
Alice: So, can we go in now?
Jake:呃理论上是这么回事
Jake: Uh, theoretically, yes.
Jake:但是可能会补这么
Jake: But maybe it needs some touch-ups.
Jake:就是不要太大的变化就行
Jake: Just don't make any big changes.
Alice:那还是别动了
Alice: Then let's not move anything.
其他人：在外面呆着吧挺好的
Others: Staying outside is fine.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:偷偷的听
Alice: Listen secretly.
Alice:你想去北语玩吗
Alice: Do you want to visit BLCU?
Alice:啊北语有那个什么文化节
Alice: Ah, BLCU is having some kind of cultural festival.
Alice:就是他们不是好多外国的吗
Alice: They have a lot of foreigners, right?
Alice:北北京语言大学
Alice: Beijing Language and Culture University.
Alice:你想去吗
Alice: Do you want to go?
Alice:想周日还是6
Alice: On Sunday or the 6th?
Alice:忘了27还是26啊
Alice: I forgot if it's the 27th or the 26th.
其他人：总是占我周六周日的时间啊
Others: It always takes up my Saturdays and Sundays.
其他人：天呐
Others: Oh my God.
Alice:什么意思啊
Alice: What do you mean?
Alice:什么叫占你周六周日的时间
Alice: What do you mean taking up your weekends?
其他人：难得休息时光啊
Others: Rarely get to rest.
Jake:啊你们平时都
Jake: Ah, you usually...
Jake:平时都可以出去是吧
Jake: You can usually go out, right?
Alice:也不是
Alice: Not really.
其他人：嗯也行
Others: Well, it’s okay.
Alice:什么时候上你家玩
Alice: When can we visit your place?
其他人：嗯等你把古筝课上完了之后哈哈
Others: Hmm, after you finish your guzheng class, haha.
Alice:哎侮辱我
Alice: Hey, that's insulting.
Alice:我还以为什么鸡吃完了米
Alice: I thought the chicken finished the rice.
Alice:狗啃完了面
Alice: And the dog finished the flour.
Alice:蜡烛烧断了锁
Alice: The candle burned the lock.
其他人：山无棱天地合
Others: Mountains crumble, earth and sky unite.
Alice:真服了
Alice: I'm really impressed.
Alice:这周
Alice: This week.
Alice:今天几号
Alice: What's the date today?
Alice:22哎那不就这周吗
Alice: The 22nd, isn't that this week?
其他人：22
Others: The 22nd.
Alice:不是下周
Alice: Not next week.
其他人：这周
Others: This week.
Alice:这周六还是5
Alice: This Saturday or the 5th?
Alice:忘了
Alice: I forgot.
Alice:但我还没搞到票呢
Alice: But I haven't got the tickets yet.
Alice:我求一下北语的同学
Alice: I'll ask my classmates at BLCU.
Alice:卑躬屈膝一下
Alice: I'll beg them.
Alice:求求你了
Alice: Please.
Alice:哈哈他今年不对外开放
Alice: Haha, it's not open to the public this year.
Alice:求一下没关系
Alice: But it's okay to ask.
Alice:那只有一天去北语
Alice: So, we only go to BLCU for one day.
Alice:另外一天干嘛
Alice: What about the other day?
其他人：你不歇一会
Others: Don't you want to take a break?
Alice:紫竹园公园
Alice: At Zizhuyuan Park.
Alice:哈哈哈这么大点劲
Alice: Hahaha, it's so small.
其他人：这么大点地
Others: It's such a small place.
其他人：连轴转我天哪
Others: Non-stop, oh my god.
Alice:别管
Alice: Don't worry.
Alice:我要看花
Alice: I want to see the flowers.
Alice:你去不去
Alice: Are you going?
其他人：之前也想呢
Others: I wanted to before.
其他人：哎呦我之前想跟我那个同学哎
Others: Oh, I wanted to go with my classmate.
Alice:要不咱俩找
Alice: How about we...
Alice:找几个那个比较光滑的石头
Alice: Find some smooth stones.
Alice:咱俩玩丢石子吧
Alice: And play stone throwing.
Jake:咋玩呢
Jake: How do you play it?
其他人：你这是同情妹妹
Others: Are you sympathizing with your sister?
Alice:就是找那种比较圆的
Alice: Just find the round ones.
Jake:嗯然后呢
Jake: And then?
Alice:这样抓嘛
Alice: Grab it like this.
Alice:就这样扔
Alice: And throw it like this.
Alice:然后这样抓
Alice: Then grab it like this.
Alice:给你示范一下
Alice: Let me show you.
Jake:为啥要光滑的石子
Jake: Why do we need smooth stones?
Alice:太扁了抓不起来嘛
Alice: If they're too flat, you can't pick them up.
Alice:就比如这个还行
Alice: For example, this one is okay.
Alice:这个太扁
Alice: This one is too flat.
Alice:不要
Alice: Don't use this one.
Alice:这个也不行
Alice: This one won't work either.
Alice:扁的要要命
Alice: It's way too flat.
Alice:这样嘛哎呀
Alice: Like this... oh no.
Alice:他没看见
Alice: He didn't see it.
Jake:哎呀再来再来
Jake: Oh no, try again, try again.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh!
Alice:这是最最基础的吗
Alice: Is this the most basic level?
Jake:啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Alice:这不最基础的吗就这样
Alice: Isn't this the most basic level? Just like this.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:可二楼可以
Jake: But the second floor is okay.
Jake:一楼不行
Jake: The first floor isn't.
Alice:然后还有比较难的
Alice: Then there's a harder level.
Alice:但是比较难的我已经忘了不会玩了
Alice: But I've already forgotten how to play the harder one.
Alice:小时候玩的
Alice: I played it when I was a kid.
Alice:最多最多是4个哎呦
Alice: The most I could do was four... oh!
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:哎不对一一一楼也
Jake: Wait, no, the first floor also...
Jake:哎一楼也行都都行
Jake: Wait, the first floor works too, they all work now.
Jake:现在都行
Jake: Now they all work.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
其他人：呃扔一抓二是吧
Others: Uh, you throw one and catch two, right?
Alice:第一个是扔一抓一
Alice: First, you throw one and catch one.
Alice:然后扔一抓二扔一抓三
Alice: Then you throw one and catch two, throw one and catch three.
Alice:然后还有别人给你扔
Alice: And then someone else throws it for you.
Alice:比如说他扔的
Alice: For example, he throws it.
Alice:比如他给你扔的
Alice: For example, he throws it for you.
Alice:你这你这次要丢一抓二
Alice: Then you have to throw one and catch two.
Alice:然后他他给你扔了这两个
Alice: And he throws these two for you.
Alice:然后你这样就得这样就要很快这种
Alice: So you have to be really quick like this.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:对对啊
Alice: Yes, exactly.
Jake:扔一抓二
Jake: Throw one and catch two.
Alice:然后或者是他给你扔的特别近
Alice: Or maybe he throws it really close to you.
Alice:然后这这把你要一丢一抓一
Alice: Then you need to throw one and catch one.
Alice:然后你这样特别小心
Alice: And you have to be very careful.
Alice:这个就不能动
Alice: You can't move this.
Alice:动了就输了
Alice: If you move, you lose.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:很多然后还有什么
Alice:这样背着抓的就很多
Alice: There are many ways to catch with your back.
Alice:没玩过啊
Alice: Haven't you played?
Alice:小时候
Alice: When you were a kid?
其他人：你看我扔一抓一都不一定能抓住哈哈
Others: Look, even my one throw and catch one isn't stiff anymore, haha.
Jake:哈哈我试试
Jake: Haha, let me try.
Alice:然后还有啊
Alice: And there's more.
Jake:扔一抓一
Jake: Throw one and catch one.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈这样
Alice: Hahahahahaha, like this.
Jake:这不是扔一抓一哈哈哈
Jake: This isn't throw one and catch one, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈好好好好好好
Alice: Hahahaha, alright, alright, alright.
Alice:然后还有什么
Alice: What else?
Alice:拿着一个
Alice: Hold one.
Alice:然后这样
Alice: And then like this.
Alice:扔上去的时候把这个放下来拿
Alice: When you throw it up, put this one down and catch it.
Alice:就再接着这个
Alice: And then catch this one again.
Alice:哎反正挺多的
Alice: Anyway, there are many ways.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Alice:小时候比较会玩
Alice: I was good at it as a kid.
Alice:长大了脑子转不过来了手脚跟不上了
Alice: Growing up, my brain can't keep up, and my hands and feet are slow.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:试试
Jake: Let me try.
Jake:扔一抓一
Jake: Throw one and catch one.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:哎哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hey, hahaha.
其他人：是天赋异禀
Others: It's a natural talent.
Alice:天赋异禀
Alice: Natural talent.
Alice:先天抓石子升级哈哈哈
Alice: First, catch the pebbles and level up, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈不行了
Jake: Haha, I can't do it anymore.
Alice:呵呵还有左手的
Alice: Haha, there's also the left hand.
Alice:太平了就抓不起来不好抓
Alice: If it's too flat, it's hard to catch.
Jake:确实太平不好抓
Jake: It's really hard to catch when it's too flat.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Jake:嗯太平打石漂
Jake: Hmm, skipping stones
Jake:打打打水漂
Jake: Skipping, skipping stones
Jake:石漂是什么
Jake: What is skipping stones?
Jake:打石漂真
Jake: Really skipping stones
Jake:你看打了两下
Jake: Look, it skipped twice
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:多少两下
Jake: How many skips?
Alice:你砸我我跟你说
Alice: If you hit me, I'm telling you
Alice:我拿这个眼镜接你
Alice: I'll catch you with these glasses
Alice:今天就不要走了
Alice: You're not leaving today
Alice:我告诉你
Alice: I'm telling you
Alice:你想玩小狗吗
Alice: Do you want to play with the puppy?
Jake:有真狗啊
Jake: Is there a real dog?
Jake:那边有有真的狗
Jake: There is a real dog over there
Alice:有真的狗
Alice: There's a real dog
Jake:对那边是真的狗
Jake: Yeah, there's a real dog over there
其他人：我自己走
Others: I'll go by myself
Alice:求我啊
Alice: Beg me
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：走不走
Others: Are we going or not?
Alice:等会先不要走
Alice: Wait, don't go yet
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈你懂啥
Alice: Hahaha, you know nothing
Alice:那边可多那个2月蓝
Alice: There are a lot of those in February
Alice:咱俩去偷吧这朵花
Alice: Blue, let's steal this flower
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha
Jake:这什么活动这都是
Jake: What kind of event is this?
Jake:这都什么世界
Jake: What kind of world is this?
Jake:地球活动
Jake: Earth event
Alice:偷花摸狗哈哈哈
Alice: Stealing flowers and petting dogs, hahaha
其他人：小偷派对
Others: Thieves' party
Alice:偷感超级偷感
Alice: Stealing feels super stealing
Alice:哪有小猫
Alice: Where's the kitten?
Alice:哦对对对
Alice: Oh right, right
Alice:我记起来了
Alice: I remember now
Alice:白白猫是吧
Alice: The white cat, right?
其他人：两只白猫
Others: Two white cats
Alice:偷一只回去呗
Alice: Let's steal one back.
其他人：你能不能
Others: Can you...
其他人：哈哈哈偷来偷去的
Others: Hahaha, stealing and stealing.
其他人：哈哈哈超级偷感
Others: Hahaha, super thief vibes.
Alice:我是个小偷
Alice: I am a thief.
Alice:我不想这偷
Alice: I don't want to steal.
Alice:这是我的本职工作
Alice: It's my main job.
Alice:我爱岗敬业
Alice: I love my work.
Jake:就像打了成功
Jake: Just like hitting success.
Alice:老板的爱好
Alice: Boss's hobby.
Jake:准备烤石头
Jake: Preparing to roast stones.
Alice:可以可以哈哈哈
Alice: Sure, sure, hahaha.
Jake:烤老板喜欢烤石头
Jake: Boss likes to roast stones.
Alice:真的有炒石头的
Alice: There's really stone frying.
Jake:是是是
Jake: Yes, yes.
Alice:然后就是然后
Alice: Then, then...
Alice:他们那个石头可以缩
Alice: They can shrink the stones.
Jake:放点老干妈是吧对
Jake: Add some Lao Gan Ma, right?
Jake:又差点
Jake: Almost missed it.
Alice:你不劳而获
Alice: You get something for nothing.
Jake:哎我靠
Jake: Oh my gosh.
其他人：去不去嘛
Others: Are you going or not?
Alice:这是啥梗
Alice: What's the joke?
Alice:你都能接上
Alice: You can even pick that up.
Alice:这互联网烂梗王
Alice: Internet joke king.
Alice:你是小偷
Alice: You are a thief.
Alice:你说谁小偷
Alice: Who are you calling a thief?
其他人：你自己说
Others: You said it yourself.
其他人：你自己的本质是小偷
Others: You said your nature is a thief.
Alice:我说啥你信啥是吧
Alice: You believe whatever I say, right?
其他人：那是自然
Others: Naturally.
其他人：你都这么说了
Others: You said it yourself.
Alice:我说我说
Alice: I said, I said...
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Alice:看还有多少story
Alice: Let's see how many stories are left.
Alice:嗯哼哼哼哼
Alice: Hmm hmm hmm hmm hmm.
Alice:只有12个g了
Alice: Only 12G left.
Jake:好收了吧
Jake: Alright, let's wrap it up.
Alice:不够录了
Alice: Not enough to record.
Jake:不录了
Jake: No more recording.
Alice:那就complete了
Alice: Then it's complete.
Jake:complete了
Jake: It's complete.